think of the universe as like a war
between habit and Novelty that's the
great dualism habit it means repetition
of pattern momentum entropy that's habit
and Novelty means symmetry breaking new
connections and Advance into the
future and so this e and Flow of novalty
versus habit is the real story of how
the universe works but science has not
even talked
about and what we really need is an
entirely new view of what time
is the view of time that we're operating
with is the view that time is like a
perfectly smooth the surface every
moment is potentially like every other
moment if you're measuring the charge of
the electron it doesn't matter whether
you do it on a Tuesday or a Sunday
because time is assumed to be an
absolute perfect featuress
plane but when you look at nature
nothing has this mathematical Perfection
everything is
modifi so why not
think
as an
irre
the
different the
kind experience the world world that
we're where there's gain and loss
novelty and habit years of boredom
sudden surises everything ruled by the
unexpected science builds beautiful
models but they don't come anywhere near
to the felt experience of Our Lives
that's the thing I mean it's one thing
to be able to predict the path of a
artillery shell or an electron but what
we want to understand is how do Affairs
work how do Empires fall how do people
fall in love these kinds of things the
things that actually make up our own
world of
[Music]
experience